hey 42 here in 1977 the world was
introduced to the most famous haunted
house in history the first line of this
not so humble abode's address 112 Ocean
Avenue might not ring any bells but the
second surely will Amityville
prior to 1977 that was the strange name
of a sleepy suburb on the outskirts of
New York City today it's synonymous with
one thing the Amityville Horror that's
the name of a book written by Jay Anson
that Chronicles the experiences of the
Lutz family who moved into 112 Ocean
Avenue a week before Christmas in 1975.
within a few days the Lutz has started
to have strange unsettling experiences
they were subtle at first inexplicable
cold spots and foul odors around the
house and in the basement was a
bricked-up room with blood red walls
which didn't appear on any of the
building plans but as the weeks went by
the Paranormal Activity escalated
George lot's Work One Nights to find his
wife levitating above their bed
a creepy demon with the face of a pig
was spotted peering through windows on
the ground floor and cloven-hoofed
Footprints appeared all around the house
after a night of heavy snowfall
family called a Catholic priest to
exercise whatever entity was Haunting
them but as soon as he whipped out the
holy water a disembodied voice barked
get out and he was slapped around the
face by an invisible hand by the time he
got home that evening fresh blisters
covered his skin and he developed wounds
on the palms of his hands that looked
suspiciously like stigmata
just 28 days after moving into their new
home the Lutz family left it in Terror
for their lives and their Immortal Souls
they didn't even bother to pack their
things
curiosity stream is the best place to
find and watch documentaries about
science technology nature travel and so
much more including my favorite section
history it's the perfect platform for
those of us who are always eager to
learn more and explore curiositystream
offers exclusive award-winning films and
shows that you can't find anywhere else
along with the deepest collection of the
best documentaries from around the world
deeper than any other streaming service
out there spanning science nature
history technology military history and
even music no matter what you're
interested in you're sure to find
something that piques your Curiosity on
curiosity stream and the best part is
that they add new shows every week
making it one of the best deals in
streaming personally I've been loving
their marks of Time series it talks
about ancient Rome and the Coliseum and
how it shaped our world and the issues
they're faced with today trying to
preserve these Ancient Wonders it's a
great one so don't miss it so if you're
ready to start exploring the world of
documentaries and non-fiction series go
to curiositystream.com 42 for unlimited
access and for my viewers you can use
promo code 42 to save 25 off that's an
incredible deal for such a wealth of
content so just click the link below or
go to
curiositystream.com42 and save 25 right
now don't miss out thanks to
curiositystream for sponsoring this
video
like many famous horror stories this
one's supposed to be true though for
obvious reasons plenty of people have
their doubts more on that later but what
very few people realize is that the most
spine chilling aspect of the entire
account is in fact completely true if
you've watched a film adaptation of the
Amityville Horror you'll recall an
estate agent informing the Lutz that a
mere year before six people were
murdered in the house those murders
really did take place and to this day
exactly how and why they were carried
out remains a mystery some suspect Mafia
involvement others believe the killer
had help from an unidentified accomplice
and still others blame whatever
Malignant Force festers within the house
but one thing is for certain in this
case the reality really is far scarier
than Fiction this is the true story of
The Amityville Horror
in the early hours of the 13th of
November 1974 23 year old Ronald Butch
Defoe left his home at 112 Ocean Avenue
he worked at his father's car dealership
but as the son of the boss his main
responsibility was to sit around on his
ass all day doing bugger all before
clocking off early to head to the pub
unlike his son Butch's father was
usually pretty conscientious but for
some reason that particular morning he
failed to show up for work
it wasn't like Ronald senior to take a
day off and it was practically unheard
of for him to do so without telling
someone Butch called home from the
dealership to find out what was going on
but nobody answered the phone
that was Art too Butch lived with his
parents and His Four siblings and there
was almost always someone at home
Butch was befuddled but went on with his
day as usual he left early and went to
see his girlfriend before heading to the
local bar to meet some friends around
6PM throughout the day he called home
periodically but there was still no
answer
by this point but was beginning to get
worried so he left his friends at the
bar and walked a five or so minutes home
the family's cars were parked in a drive
but the front door was locked and when
he rang the doorbell nobody answered
Butch didn't have a key so he nipped
around the back of the house and climbed
in for an unlocked window inside he soon
discovered why nobody had been answering
the phone all day every member of his
family was dead
shortly thereafter the police turned up
to a grizzly scene Butch's parents and
His Four siblings were all found lying
face down in their beds shot by an
unknown assailant
Amityville was simply not the kind of
place where such Horrors happened and
the local police were baffled there was
no sign of a forced entry and nothing
had been stolen struggling to see a
motive for the crime they asked Butch
who was now sobbing uncontrollably
whether he knew anyone who might have
wanted to hurt his family as it happened
he did butcher's great uncle Peter Defoe
was a Kappa regime in the Genovese crime
family in other words he was Mafia a few
years earlier one of Peter's criminal
colleagues a Hitman Louis Fellini had
laid low at the Defoe residence for
several weeks during that time Fellini
and Butch's father apparently fell out
Butch thoughts the murders might be some
kind of Payback
fearing Fellini might Target the soul
Defoe family survivor Butch was taken
into custody for his own protection
the police meanwhile began searching the
house for Clues and it wasn't long
before they made a break for it to their
surprise the vital evidence wasn't found
near any of the bodies but in the only
bedroom the killer apparently hadn't
visited butchers tucked away in a corner
where a couple of empty cardboard boxes
which turned out to be the packaging for
two Marlin rifles one or 22 caliber and
the other are 35 and sure enough the
police later confirmed the murder weapon
was a 35 caliber Marlin rifle
unsurprisingly suspicion Bethel Butch
and his story started to shatter in his
statement he told the police exactly
what I just told you that he got up
early went to work then visited his
girlfriend went to the bar and finally
discovered his entire family dead in
their beds
that was plausible enough and Butch had
solid Alibis for all of it but there was
one small problem according to Butch the
murders occurred after he left for work
but forensics findings put the time of
death at between 2 and 4 AM since Butch
claimed to have left the house sometime
after 4am he would have been home during
the murders
[Music]
cornered by his own testimony Butch
immediately changed it claiming he was
indeed at home when Fellini murdered his
family but for some reason the Hitman
had decided to spare him it was an
obvious lie but why had Butch spent half
a day feigning concern for his family if
he knew they were already dead why
hadn't he reported the crime as soon as
Fellini left and for that matter why
even lie in the first place
unsurprisingly Butch had no answer to
any of these questions and with his
flimsy Fable torn to shreds he made a
full confession in his own chilling
words once I started I just couldn't
stop it all went so fast
detailing his deeds that morning the
sheer evilness of butcher's crime
emerged after murdering his entire
family in Cold Blood Butch had a nice
relaxing soak in the bath got changed
then drove out of town to dispose of the
a murder weapon and his blood-stained
clothes in a storm drain as we've
already seen in an attempt to further
cover his tracks he proceeded to have a
completely normal day going to work
hanging out with his girlfriend and
having good drinks with his mates all
whilst the bodies of his entire family
grew cold in their beds at home
[Music]
Butch was put on trial for six counts of
murder his defense lawyer William Weber
tried to convince the Jory Butch was
innocent on the grounds of insanity but
deploy failed Butch was sentenced to six
consecutive jail terms of 25 years one
for each of the family members he'd
slain
in many ways it was an open and shut
case along with butcher's confession
there was a whole boatload of evidence
that he was the killer but when you
think about it several aspects of the
crime just don't had up Butch Defoe
fired eight shots that night a pair for
each parent and one for each sibling and
forensics confirmed the bodies hadn't
moved post-mortem meaning all six
members of the family were slain in
their beds
[Music]
as you've probably noticed guns are loud
the house at 112 Ocean Avenue is pretty
big and the bedrooms are split across
two floors it would have taken but
several minutes to move from room to
room as he systematically snuffed his
nearest and dearest which leads us to a
very obvious question how the hell did
nobody wake up
Butch himself explains this little
conundrum by claiming to have laced a
family dinner with sleep-inducing
barbiturates but no trace of any drugs
showed up in the toxicology reports and
let's not forget about the Neighbors in
many films about The Amityville Horror
the house is shown as being relatively
remote presumably to ampop the Fear
Factor in reality it's on a regular
Street lined with lots of other houses
during butcher's trial a reenactment of
the murders revealed that a single shot
from the murder woman could be heard a
full five blocks away
and yet not a single neighborhood any of
the eight gunshots fired that night
there's also the question of motive it
was well known in Amityville that Butch
was bad news he drank heavily took drugs
and committed several Petty crimes he
also had a truly terrible and sometimes
violent relationship with his father
which had been deteriorating in the
weeks leading up to the murders but
there was no discernible motive for the
other five killings Butch was even said
to be particularly close to Dawn the
eldest of his four younger siblings even
for someone like myself with a permanent
lease on the biggest tent in the
Skeptics Camp it's all a bit strange
add it to the Lutz's story of pervasive
Paranormal Activity and demons lurking
in the dark and you have to ask yourself
is it possible that the whole thing
might actually be true that there's
something unnatural in that house
there's certainly some convincing
evidence here
in 1979 George and Kathy Lutz
volunteered for a polygraph test to
prove once and for all that their story
was true they did things properly too
recruiting Chris gigas to carry out the
test he was one of the leading polygraph
experts in America at the time the
couple were separately asked five
questions about their paranormal
experiences in the house ranging from
the simple are you telling the truth to
the slightly more specific did you
levitate that one time
Google ultimately concluded that both
were telling the truth
on the other hand you happen to be a
fellow skeptic there's ample reason to
dismiss yamityville horror as just
another hoax to start several key scenes
in the original book are demonstrably
inaccurate the Catholic priest who
apparently got beaten up by a ghost
whilst trying to bless the house later
swore in court that he'd never even been
there and those cloven hoof Footprints
has appeared in the snow all around the
house records show it didn't snow
anywhere near Amityville on the day in
question
then there's the infamous hidden Red
Room portrayed in the film as a gateway
to Hell
turns out it was merely a mundane
storage room with red paint on one of
the walls and it was never hidden as
Kathy and George Lutz claimed the kids
used to play there often which
presumably wouldn't have been a great
option if it had been a literal entrance
to the underworld
most dumbing of all in 1979 William
Weber Butch defoe's defense attorney
confessed to concocting the whole thing
with George and Kathy Lutz over copious
amounts of wine Weber revealed that it
wasn't malevolent forces but mounting
mortgage debts that convinced a lot to
flee the house
they conjured all the ghosts and Goblin
stuff to try and make some Fast Cash
and considering they earned hundreds of
thousands of dollars from The Amityville
Horror it's safe to say that went quite
well
I should also point out that several
other people have lived in the house
since the Luts and not one of them has
ever reported anything unusual in the
decades since Amityville Horror was
released the story has become a
money-making beer moth birthing over 25
films dozens of books and a load of
documentaries that I strongly urge you
to not bother watching all these
retellings have created an awful lot of
noise and now there's so much fiction
entwined with the facts it's difficult
to know what to believe ultimately
there's not a shred of actual evidence
that anything Supernatural inhabits 112
Ocean Avenue now 108 Ocean Avenue one of
the former owners changed the address in
a futile attempt to deter morbid
tourists
it's ironic that a Mr Tall Tales most
folk have forgotten the genuine horror
that haunts this house the brutal 1975
Massacre of six people Butch Defoe died
behind bars in March 2021 and during his
46 years in prison he variously
implicated everyone from his sister Dawn
their mother and a shadowy figure who
mysteriously appeared at the house one
night and handed him a gun however the
exact details changed with each
retelling ultimately we may never know
the truth but one thing is for sure what
happened that night in Amityville was
truly horrifying
thanks for watching